dann hat sich die polizei oder die
staatsanwaltschaft geäußert ja bevor wir
damit weiter anfang erstmal noch zu dem
wohnort ihr die nachbarn haben uns auch
erzählt dass bereits vor zwei wochen die
polizei hier war und nach samana gesucht
hat warum ist immer noch unklar
die staatsanwaltschaft und die polizei
haben jetzt eine gemeinsame mitteilung
herausgegeben darunter darin bestätigen
sie eigentlich unsere berichte und
erklären dass samantha nach bisherigem
ermittlungsstand wohl gezielt auch auf
motorradfahrer zugerast
motorradfahrer sind natürlich auf einer
autobahn ein sehr leichtes opfer und was
nicht dann auch den tod herbeizuführen
jetzt wird gegen ihn ermittelt wegen
versuchten mordes in gewahrsam und die
polizei und die staatsanwaltschaft
wollen sich gegen 13 uhr in einer
sondersendung dazu äußern
außerdem haben sie gesagt dass von einem
dass ein religiös islamistischer
hintergrund nicht auszuschließen ist
allerdings gibt es keine hinweise darauf
dass er in einer terroristischen
vereinigung mitglied gewesen ist
außerdem scheint er psychisch sehr labil
zu sein wie die polizei und die
staatsanwaltschaft mitgeteilt haben